On a dark night in Mill Valley, Pennsylvania
in 1968, a young Ramon Morales was in jail. On
this particular night he, and a small group
of teenagers, had been besieged by monsters
written into life by an angry spirit. One by
one, the group was picked off by creatures that
should only exist between the ancient pages of
a long forgotten book. Now… It was Ramon’s turn.
– [Jangly Man] “Me Tie Doughty Walker”.
– The Jangly Man was coming.
The 2019 film adaption of the popular horror
book series Scary Stories to Tell in the Dark
was dutiful in recreating some of the
most popular monsters from the series,
written by Alvin Schwartz and illustrated by
Stephen Gammel. Fan favorites Harold the Scarecrow
and The Pale Lady are among the creatures lifted
from the pages to walk and talk on the big screen
whose creature designs were revealed ahead
of the film. The Scary Stories fandom and
other Super Bowl viewers were stunned at that
accuracy to Gammel’s original infamous artwork.
The Jangly Man, twisting and tearing
its body apart in pursuit of Ramon,
was received with awe as well for the
intense visage of its off-center face
and backwards limbs. There’s just one wrinkle…
The Jangly Man never existed in the original
Scary Stories series. To learn who, or
rather WHAT, The Jangly Man is, stick
around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Guardio.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History. Normally when
analyzing Horror History, I’d begin with
the source material – in this case the book –
and venture forward from there. In this case,
however, we’re starting with
the 2019 film adaptation and,
much like the Jangly Man himself, going
“backwards” to the original three-book series.
The film adaptation is less of a
direct continuity with book series,
and more of a remix of elements from the
stories. A somewhat comparable example would
be the new “40 Year Trilogy” in the Halloween
universe. In Halloween (2018), Kills, and Ends,
we see elements of all the old Halloween
movies mixed and matched to tell a new story.
In Scary Stories, the newly added character
Sarah Bellows is the author of the literal
scary stories featured in the movie. In the
past, the Bellows were a prominent family in
Mill Valley. Though active in the community
and respected, there was a hidden dark side.
– [Stella] The Bellows had a secret,
a daughter they never allowed to leave
the house. The myth is that there
was something really off about her.
To keep her silence, Sarah was imprisoned in
the basement until her death. But legend held
that she would read her stories through the
walls to curious children on the other side.
Fast forward to the 1960s where a group of
socially awkward teens find Sarah’s magic
book and, of course, release the cursed contents
upon themselves and the town itself. RIP Tommy.
(Tommy throwing up hay)
Here’s where things take a
turn. Original Scary Stories
to Tell in the Dark book creatures are
definitely present, but The Jangly Man,
who appears as the final boss in the
film’s finale is not one of them.
– [Stella] Oh my god, what is that?
– I said the same thing. However, there are
many familiar elements. So in order to
understand – The Jangly Man – hey, I kind of like
that. We need to pull him apart piece by piece.
(roar)
(mysterious music)
Released between the early 80s and 90s,
Alvin Schwartz’s frightening plots and
Stephen Gammel’s macabre illustrations
were inspired by, if not a retelling of,
existing urban legends, historical
accounts, or folklore and folktales.
The Jangly Man was inspired
by THREE of these tales,
all included in the first
entry, Scary Stories to Tell in the Dark.
“Aaron Kelly’s Bones”, “What Do
You Come For?” And of course…
– [Jangly] Me tie doughty walker
– The Jangly Man would not be the only
example of multiple stories wrapped
up into one monster from the book. For example,
one sequence is an adaptation of “The Big Toe”,
from the first book, but the monster
with the missing toe looks more like
the illustration from “The Haunted
House”, also from the first book.
To stitch together the origins and
dynamic of The Jangly Man, we need
to understand what all three of these stories
have in common and where they all originate.
Let’s start with the opening
of “Aaron Kelly’s Bones”:
Aaron Kelly was dead. They bought him a coffin
and had a funeral and buried him. But that night
he got out of his coffin, and he came home. His
family was sitting around when he walked in.
Let’s compare this to the opening
of “What Do You Come For?”
There was an old woman who lived all by
herself, and she was very lonely. Sitting
in the kitchen one night she said, “Oh,
I wish I had some company.” No sooner had
she spoken then down the chimney tumbled
two feet from which the flesh had rotted.
Finally, we have the opening
of “Me Tie Dough-ty Walker”:
There was a haunted house where every night
a bloody head fell down the chimney. At
least that’s what people said. So
nobody would stay there overnight.
Then the rich man offered two hundred
dollars to whoever would do it. And this
boy said he would try if he could have
his dog with him. So it was all settled.
So far we have all the activity
taking place at night, at home,
and each involves the idea of company
coming over. As all three stories progress,
the element of separated limbs is introduced.
In “Aaron Kelly’s Bones”, the titular
character dances himself apart:
The fiddler fiddled, and dead Aaron danced. Then
Aaron fell apart, collapsed into a pile of bones
– all except his bald headbone that grinned at
the fiddler, cracked its teeth –and kept dancing.
In “What Do You Come For?”
A body tumbled down, then two arms,
and a man’s head. As the woman watched,
the parts came together
into a great, gangling man.
And “Me Tie Dough-ty Walker””
Soon the boy heard the singing again.
Now it was coming down the chimney:
♪ Me tie dough-ty walker! ♪
The dog sang right back:
♪ Lynchee kinchy colly molly dingo dingo! ♪
Suddenly a bloody head fell out of the chimney.
Despite the parallels listed above,
there’s no singular entity that each
of these stories seems to be inspired
or derived from. And that’s because
The Jangly Man isn’t a legend or a
myth. This is folklore. And folklore
rarely deals with a literal creature,
but rather explores traditional concepts.
And the concept covered by “Aaron
Kelly’s Bones”, “What Do You Come For”,
and “Me Tie Dough-ty Walker” that is eventually
expanded into the 2019’s film... is death.
– [Ramon] The Jangly Man is coming.
While you may not have to worry too
much about staying safe from horrific
monsters coming out of a book, you
do still need to be vigilant about
safety when browsing the web. That
is where Guardio comes in. Guardio
is a browser extension that protects users
from online threats like malware, phishing,
and annoying browser notifications. For
example, you may have encountered dangerous
pop-ups while streaming content on other
platforms. Guardio will immediately block
malicious sites and malvertising pop-ups so
you can watch streaming without worrying.
Just add Gaurdio’s browser extension from the
Chrome or Edge web store and you’ll be able to
perform a free security scan to detect existing
threats. My entire job takes place online,
so I do my best to keep my system clean. So I
was very surprised to have all these threats.
After the scan, you get a 7-day free trial for
full protection. After that, you can decide
if you want to continue - it’s risk-free due
to their 30-day money-back guarantee policy.
Right now, Guardio is offering a special deal
-- 20% off the monthly subscription for Horror
History viewers. Because we've seen enough
horrors, we don't need them in our browser.
So - if you want a clean and secure browsing
experience, again, go to guard.io/czsworld - link
in the description and check out their
affordable premium plan for full protection.
As with most folklore and Scary Stories, there
will never really be an original source of any
tale. Even if there once was, by definition:
folklore and folktales were first shared by word
of mouth, not written down. The origins of some
folklore can stretch back past the middle ages
meaning the details, and even the tone, have
changed depending on the culture of the time.
“Harold” out of Scary Stories 3 is a good
example. He’s often referred to as a scarecrow,
yet, the term “scarecrow” is never used in the
original Scary Stories entry nor, when traced
back to his origins in the alpine regions of
Europe, does the word “scarecrow” ever come up.
The Jangly Man enters Scary Stories to
Tell in the Dark at the climatic ending.
This monster has easily the longest run time
in the film and is introduced by Ramon as a
“camp story” that really scared him as a kid.
Our two remaining heroes, Stella and Ramon,
find themselves behind bars because Ramon ran
away after being drafted into the Vietnam War.
He didn’t want to end up like this older brother,
who was shipped back to his family, in pieces.
– [Ramon] Last week when I got my
draft notice… I couldn’t. They just
send you there to die.
– [Zac] As the policeman questions them,
the power goes out and their attention is
drawn to the dog standing at the fireplace.
(grunting)
This dog seems to live at the police station, and
fills the role of the chanting dog from “Me Tie
Dough-ty Walker”, although this dog doesn't
speak. He just runs away before this happens.
(head bounces down chimney)
The stunned cop tries to shoot his new friend,
but that doesn’t seem to do much. The head is
soon joined by a cascade of limbs and its torso,
much like in the story “What Do You Come
For?”. Like many of the antagonists we’d
seen up to this point, The Jangly Man plays
on its victim’s specific fears. In this case,
Ramon’s less-than-happy memories of his brother
arriving back home in pieces after the war.
By the way, the name, The Jangly Man, comes
from the campfire story from his youth. It
seems to be a slightly altered version of
the description in “What Do You Come For?”,
which mentions the body parts coming
together into a great, gangling man.
And that is exactly what happens.
[high pitched grunting]
[growling]
The newly formed horror breaks the
cop’s neck and throws him into the
room where Stella and Ramon are captive. It
crawls over towards them as if it is a man
bent over backwards with its head twisted to
lock eyes with them in an upright position.
A little bit of behind the scenes here – The
Jangly Man is played by a contortionist named
Troy James. The previous year, he appeared
on the competition show America’s Got Talent,
where he performed his weird… Jangly walk I’ll
call it? And freaked out judges and audience
members alike. When he does this on stage, he
does so almost as a performative dance routine,
further connecting the movements to those
described in the short story “Aaron Kelly’s
Bones”. Also, one of the judges is
pretty spot on with his comments.
– I would love to see you star in a
horror film.
– Anyway, that’s enough reality TV for one decade.
The Jangly Man tries to get into Ramon’s cell
by cracking its skull in half to try to squeeze
through the narrow bars, again, bringing reminders
of the text in “Aaron Kelly’s Bones”, which
describes the dancing corpse ‘cracking his teeth’.
Stella is able to obtain the key and free
both of them before the creature passed
through the steel bars. With his sights solely
set on Ramon, the boy bravely decides to lead
the creature away from Stella in the stolen
police car. But The Jangly Man demonstrates
its incredible speed by catching up
and mounting the hood of the vehicle.
In a Michael Myers moment, he uses his hand to
smash the passenger side window from above and
Ramon tries everything he can to shake the living
nightmare loose, but to no avail. He resorts to
crashing the car into a large truck, pinning
old Jangly between the two motor vehicles,
where he falls apart piece by piece, our
last reference to “Aaron Kelly’s Bones”.
With no room to escape, Jangly's body
falls back apart, allowing him to slip
down between the police car and the
moving truck, then he reassembles
himself once more. It seems like he can break
himself apart and rebuild himself at will,
making him pretty much impossible to defeat.
He tracks Ramon back to the Bellows house,
where he flips his way onto the second floor
landing... like dude, there are stairs.
He breaks down the door of the room Ramon is
hiding in and stalks around on all fours looking
for him. After realizing that Ramon is hiding
under a table, he perches himself on the ceiling,
and waits for his victim to come out, so he
can drop down and attack. He holds the boy
up by his neck, choking him, but luckily,
for Ramon, The Jangly Man falls apart once
more as Stella convinces Sarah Bellows
to release her rage and let go of her
stories in another room, and the scattered
pieces of his body seem to just disappear.
As far as we can tell, that is the end. But it’s
not the end of this viewing session. For you.
Because I’ve got other Scary Stories episodes
lined up in that playlist to the left. If you
love horror, remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
and select all notifications, and I will see
you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
(spooky dance music)